Speaker 1: Another one of these vaccine mandate,
ne'er do wells. Is Rand Paul. From Kentucky.
Ostensibly a man of medicine, an ophthalmologist,
although not board certified, he created his
own licensing organization to license himself.
These people, he took to a video to explain
in a very aggressive manner how he will not
be bossed around, you're not the boss of me,
Nancy Pelosi. Watch this.
Speaker 4: It's time for us to resist. They
can't arrest all of us. They can't keep all
of your kids home from school.
Speaker 1: It starts off in grand fashion.
They can't kill all of us. They can arrest
all of us. They can't persecute all of us.
This is what this is boiled down to for these
types, Rand Paul, who has absolutely eradicated
any credibility he once had, if he had any
at all, he has become an absolute Trump lackey,
a Trump automaton. He's a a facsimile of Donald
Trump, especially related to this particular
topic. We will unfortunately let him continue.
Speaker 4: They can't keep every government
building closed.
Speaker 1: Avoid if you like to
Speaker 4: keep closed or might ought to keep
closed. We don't have to accept the mandates,
lockdowns and harmful policies of the petty
tyrants and bureaucrats. We can simply say
no, not
Speaker 1: petty tyrants and bureaucrats,
petty tyrants. To Rand Paul and many who follow
him. They believe that, A, that a, that a
public health measure to keep children and
the the infirmed people who are especially
vulnerable to infection, that keeping them
safe and healthy is Taraneh. I would love
to see a Rand Paul put back in time travel
across the eons to to a time when there were
revolutionary machinations in the colonies.
And see how he would have stood up. There's
a lot of talk about our founding fathers risked
their treasure and their reputations and their
sacred honor to enter into the revolution,
to free us and make us independent from Great
Britain. Is this does he have the medal for
that, I say no,
Speaker 4: Nancy Pelosi, you will not arrest
or stop me or anyone on my staff from doing
our jobs. We have either had covered had the
vaccine or been offered the vaccine. We will
make our own health choices. We will not show
you a passport. We will not wear a mask. We
will not be forced into random screenings
and testings. So you can
Speaker 1: all this means is we will not care
for our fellow Americans. We will not be concerned
with the health and well-being of our neighbors.
We don't care about that. We're too busy owning
the Libs. I dare say Rand Paul's neighbor
did not go far enough.
Speaker 4: Continue your drunk with power
reign over the capital. President Biden, we
will not accept your agency's mandates or
your reported moves towards a lockdown. No
one should follow the CDC s antiscience mask
mandates. And if you want to shut down federal
agencies again, some of which aren't even
back to work yet, I will stop every bill coming
through the Senate with an amendment to cut
their funding if they don't come back to work
in person
Speaker 1: because this is a pattern and practice
for Rand Paul. I'm going to I'm going to gum
up the works, because that's all I'm good
at, I'm going to vote against this. I'm going
to vote against amendments. I'm going to offer
amendments that have no chance of passage
in order that I slow down the mechanism of
the Senate to slow any progress that might
be made in the course of signing legislation
into law by the president. Unbelievable, the
temerity of this man,
Speaker 4: bureaucrats and union bosses, we
will not allow you to do more harm to our
children again this year, children are not
at any more risk from covid than they are
from the seasonal flu.
Speaker 1: With this Dr. Drew over here. We
are witnessing a massive spike in infections
of children, of hospitalization of children.
And he stands here purporting to care about
kids while doing everything in his power to
ensure that those spikes only increase, that
we see more death, more destruction, more
mayhem at the hands of the virus, getting
a little assist from Republican politicians
everywhere.
Speaker 4: Every adult who works in schools
has either had the vaccine or had their chance
to get vaccinated. There is no reason for
mask mandates, part time schools or any lockdown
measures. Children are falling behind in school
and are being harmed physically and psychologically
by the tactics that you have used to keep
them from the classroom during the last year.
We won't allow it again. If a school system
attempts to keep children from full time in-person
school, I will hold up every bill with two
amendments one to defund them and another
to allow parents the choice of where the money
goes for their child's education. Do I sound
fed up to you? That's because I am. I'm not
a career politician.
Speaker 1: Oh, come on, Rand Paul. You can
do better than that, brother. I'm not a career
politician. Since when? Guy you've been in
the Senate a long time. You've been in government
a long time. I don't see you stepping away
to go work on ice any time soon. You're absolutely
a career politician who again, your only move
your go to is to threaten to gum up the works
to threaten obstructionism. That's all you
got. You're a reactionary ghoul watching millions
of Americans get the virus, hundreds of thousands
of them die. We don't know where the ceiling
of death is in this country. And the reason
we don't know, the reason we cannot estimate
is because of monsters like you, ghouls like
you